eine schulfeier im vornehmen nobelort
starnberg bei münchen ist im sommer 2019
komplett eskaliert 70 beamte waren nötig
um die situation unter kontrolle zu
bringen
heute steht der schlüssel mob jetzt vor
gericht hier noch einmal die ganze
unfassbare geschichte [ __ ] und
dreckschwein nur einige der rufe die
polizisten entgegen schalten als ein mob
aus schülern im letzten jahr ein
polizeirevier stürmte jetzt geht es für
fünf der randalierenden schüler vor
gericht
die szenen wurden ende juli 2009 10 bei
einem schulfest im nobelort starnberg
bei münchen aufgenommen und hatten in
folge für bundesweites aufsehen gesorgt
auslöser für die randale war die
polizeikontrolle das 15 jährigen samuel
es der dunkelhäutige teenager hatte den
sicherheitsdienst des gymnasiums um
drogen angebettelt sich dann gegen eine
durchsuchung gewährt als freunde
versuchten ihn aus dem gewahrsam zu
befreien eskalierte die situation
ein wütender schüler mob versuchte die
polizeiwache zu stürmen schlug auf
polizisten einen und cervar fenster ab
heute müssen sich fünf der schüler vorm
amtsgericht starnberg für ihre taten
verantworten
neben samuel es stehen noch drei weitere
minderjährige schüler sowie der
20-jährige privat schüler felix m vorm
richter
es geht um tätlichen angriff auf
vollstreckungsbeamte und andere delikte
den prozess um die fünf vermeintlich
feinen schüler begleitet für uns bild
reporter jörg völkerling drei
verhandlungstage will sich amtsrichter
ralph viele zeit nehmen die geschehnisse
rund um das sommerfest des gymnasiums im
noblen ski ort starnberg aufzuarbeiten
die fünf angeklagten darunter vier noch
minderjährige schüler werden diese zeit
wohl auch dazu nutzen den spieß
umzudrehen und die polizisten
übermäßiger gewalt zu bezichtigen
der 15 jährige realschüler von dem die
randale damals ausging und hat bereits
kurz nach seiner festnahme über seinen
anwalt vier beamte beim lka anzeigen
lassen das ermittlungsverfahren wegen
körperverletzung im amt wurde aber
inzwischen eingestellt den 15 jährigen
angeklagten bringt das den zusätzlichen
tat vorwurf der falschen verdächtigung 1
ohnehin ist er schon früher aufgefallen
durch despektierliche verhalten
gegenüber polizeibeamten auch ein
ladendiebstahl und landfriedensbruch
zuletzt nicht stehen in der
anklageschrift
den fünf angeklagten drohen theoretisch
bis zu drei jahre haft oder geldstrafe
wahrscheinlich weil jugendstrafrecht ist
allerdings eine einer rest oder eine
weisung zu sozialstunden sechs weitere
beteiligte der randale werden aufgrund
ihres alters erst im november nicht
öffentlich verhandelt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren